you
in part one of this video we looked at
the procedures the world has in place
for the event of first contact with
alien life now we're going to get to the
fun part the possible scenarios and
types of extraterrestrial civilizations
let's get right into it most experts
believe that there are two overarching
categories into which all possible alien
civilizations can be placed friendly and
hostile each of these categories can be
further divided into more specific
groups such as friendly or hostile
nomads friendly or hostile
interplanetary refugees and so on let's
start by looking at hostile
extraterrestrial arrival scenarios
before we do it's important to note that
much of the scientific community holds
the opinion that any civilization
advanced enough to travel between star
systems will have no need for violence
and we therefore have little to fear
from alien arrival for the sake of
curiosity
we'll still explore a few possibilities
imagine your favorite alien invasion
movie what do you picture probably
weapons beyond human understanding
usually on a massive scale right there's
a reason that trope has become so
prevalent and it's not just because the
explosions are cool any spacefaring
civilization able to reach earth would
have the ability to harness energy in
ways we've yet to even consider and it
stands to reason that such forms of
energy would be used not only as
propulsion but also as a form of weapon
unlike our science fiction movies depict
scientists believe that any aggressive
alien civilization would be able to
eradicate humanity with little effort
but what would drive intelligent beings
to such acts of aggression it could be
any of several reasons the most likely
being either a need for resources or the
drive to expand and colonize
coincidentally Seth Shostak the SETI
researcher referenced in part 1 of this
video is one of the scientists who
suspects the quest for natural resources
would result in violence he believes
that since there can be assumed to be a
finite amount of natural resources in
the galaxy it stands to reason that
advanced civilizations would fight over
them as we do on earth
of course resources are so abundant in
the universe in different forms and
locations that it does seem rather
far-fetched that a super intelligent
alien civilization would need to resort
to mining earth that being said if such
a civilization did in fact come knocking
on our door there's little we could do
to stop them as for the drive for
colonization and expansion humanity
understands that goal all too well the
history of man is the history of
conquest war for power glory and first
for most the spread of national borders
consider Alexander the Great who at the
age of 20 succeeded his father as king
of Macedon and by the age of 30 had
built one of the largest empires in the
ancient world stretching all the way
from Greece to Northwestern India if a
young man of twenty could conquer such a
huge area imagine what a civilization
thousands of years more advanced than
ours could accomplish colonization often
under the guise of protection or
cultural advancement is intended not
only to gain a foothold in the occupied
territory but also to exploit economic
opportunities and assimilate the natives
into the invaders Imperial culture take
for example the Roman Empire over its
many years of dominance the Roman Empire
colonized large parts of Western Europe
North Africa and West Asia in Africa and
Asia the Romans often moved in and
allowed the civilized inhabitants to
assimilate into the new hybrid Roman
culture while in Europe the Roman Empire
often resorted to using military force
on the disjointed tribes living in their
desired locations strong-arming them
into submission an invasive alien
civilization could easily play the role
of the Roman Empire to such an advanced
species humanity would likely seem
nothing more than cattle to be
shepherded assimilated or eradicated I
will having a foothold on earth molding
humanity into a hybrid human alien
society would allow the intelligent
civilization to effectively claim earth
as their own leave a handful of
enforcers and then continue on their way
to colonize new planets as scary as
these scenarios are it's important to
keep in mind that the majority of
scientists suspect that advanced alien
civilizations will have transcended the
need for violence and will harbor no ill
will towards humanity with that in mind
let's look at the positive scenarios of
alien arrival while it's probably true
that any hyper advanced civilization
could destroy humanity with the push of
a button many scientists and thinkers
suspect that such beings would instead
remember their own violent past and
strive to help humanity avoid
destruction futurist Allen tuff suggests
three approaches a friendly civilization
might use to aid the people of Earth one
intervention only to prevent catastrophe
this approach would involve our alien
friends simply monitoring Earth's
activity and stepping and only when
disaster is inevitable such as in the
case of an all-out nuclear war or an
asteroid collision to advise and action
with consent this approach would be more
hands on or tentacles on or whatever the
case may be it would involve the
extraterrestrials advising world leaders
and acting
their consent to prevent danger three
forcible corrective actions this would
be the most intrusive method and would
involve the extraterrestrials compelling
humanity to take steps to reduce major
risks against our will intending to help
humans advance to the next stage of
civilization
according to tough option to advice an
action with consent is far more likely
than forcible corrective action he
believes that while the aliens would
know their methods and practices are
superior to ours it would be detrimental
to interspecies relations to force
humanity to act against its own wishes
others suggest that advanced
civilizations would first instruct
humanity on morality and ethics before
providing us with technology were not
yet prepared to use possibly destroying
ourselves in the process another line of
thought called the zoo hypothesis
suggests that an advanced civilization
may even avoid contact with humanity at
all instead opting to observe us from
afar allowing our fledgling civilization
to develop naturally at its own pace it
proposes that any advanced civilization
will understand that humanity could
suffer a sort of loss of identity if
they were to provide us with galactic
training wheels so to speak and protect
us from danger like an overbearing
parent though the thought of hostile
civilizations is scary it's nice to know
that the majority of experts believe
advanced life forms will be friendly
whether we ever meet them is another
matter entirely
but it sure is comforting to think that
we might have a super intelligent big
brother out there among the stars if
you'd like to learn more about the
theories behind advanced alien
civilizations or the history of
colonization check out the links in the
description if you enjoyed this video
please take a moment to subscribe to my
channel to keep up to date with the
latest content feel free to leave a like
or a dislike as you please and leave a
comment down below with how you think we
would interact with alien civilizations
you can watch part 1 of this video by
clicking here or watch all of my videos
by clicking here thanks for watching and
I'll see you in the next video